bonjour alexis paulhan merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france avec ce
projet de loin le gouvernement et ce
qu'elle s'est mis dans une impasse
législatives à votre avis oui ça paraît
compliqué on voit bien que encore une
fois émaillé le maquereau et son
gouvernement ainsi que ses députés de la
majorité voulait passer en force en
faisant fi du débat parlementaire
il en est finalement qu'on peut changer
les règles d'un pays comme on change les
règles de la communauté d'un réseau
social comme facebook ou twitter
c'est pas le cas la république la france
c'est un pays il y à une démocratie on
doit débattre avec les représentants de
la nation les élus et on ne peut pas des
gouvernés par décret imposé comme ça un
changement de vie à des millions de
français au coeur de l'été d'une semaine
sur l'autre en jouant avec leur mère en
jouant aussi avec leur liberté ce qui se
passe actuellement avec spa sanitaire
c'est un débat profond qui doit être
sûre à la fois la réelle utilité de ce
pass puisqu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que
les contrôles seraient extrêmement
délicate difficile que la contamination
continuent que la vaccination certes
limites mais n'empêche pas la
propagation du virus
donc on est vraiment là dedans dans un
moment où la crise sanitaire a été
utilisé et ça depuis le début comme un
accélérateur de contrôle social et de
gestion sécuritaire de cette crise
c'était le cas avec la loi sécurité et
terrorisme l'utilisation des drones
massive et voilà que tout revient avec
ce pass sanitaire avec en seul dernier
rempart le conseil constitutionnel qui
devra statuer sur cette loi qui devient
totalement muet ce cas il est question
maintenant de d'un an d'emprisonnement
de 15 mille euros damende si vous ne
flashent est pas le qr code d'un
restaurant oublié de mettre votre nom
sur la petite piste à l'entrée d'aidés
amende de 45000 euros pour les
restaurateurs bref on est en plein
délire législatif une sorte de
surabondance pour une revue est
difficile à appliquer encore une fois au
la porte est d'ailleurs critiquable donc
évidemment emmanuel macron découvre
qu'il ya un parlement et qu'il faut
parler et débattre parce que nous sommes
en démocratie je ne lui en déplaise
alors le contexte n'est pas forcément
évident pour emmanuel macron il ya de
grandes manifestations qui sont attendus
ce week end à ce que le président
finalement il
et en quelque sorte les gilet jaune oui
on pourrait dire alors pas que les
jeunes je crois que dans la rue il ya
énormément de gens inquiets sur la façon
dont cette crise a été gérée parce que
encore une fois cette gestion
sécuritaire n'est là que pour masquer
l'indigence de la gestion de crise par
jean castex et emmanuel macron la
lenteur de la vaccination début le
manque de doses pourquoi vouloir imposer
un passé ni terre alors que tous les
français ne peuvent pas se faire
vacciner même ceux qui le désirent
pourquoi aussi avoir menti sur les
masques au début de cette crise les
petites phrases dans l'évier vers ans
qu'ils sont là pour diviser pour casser
les français pour se moquer d'eux
également avec toujours cette france
d'en bas fumeurs de club qui ne veut pas
travailler alors qu'il est ministre de
la santé et des solidarités il faudrait
le rappeler donc oui il y a un vrai
rappelle finalement d'un peuple
politique qui est là et qui est là pour
rappeler que oui c'est une démocratie
cui il va falloir débattre et que ce
n'est pas le roi qui décident parce que
nous sommes en 5ème république même si
ce régime aujourd'hui montrent toutes
ses limites et donc oui je pense que là
et moselle mc mois a réveillé quelque
chose qui le dépasse qui pourrait aller
très loin alors on voit bien qu'ils
préparent de toute façon une réponse
répressive à la fois avec les amandes à
la difficulté que qui sera fait aux
français pour voyager pour se mouvoir
pour voir les d'appoint un point b qui
va à l'encontre de tous les traités
européens à l'encontre de toutes nos
valeurs
et puis la police aussi qu' elle n'a pas
obligation vaccinale mais qui par contre
cela là pour contrôler les passes
sanitaires et pour contrôler également
les débordements s'il devait y en avoir
dans la rue donc vraiment on est on vit
un moment critique à la fois l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi dans les rues alors
même que nous sommes pendant les
vacances d'été plutôt un moment calme
pour les français donc c'est vous dire
comment le mal est profond et comment
aujourd'hui le pays est en ébullition
alors la cnil à la commission nationale
de l'informatique et des libertés
hier appelé à bien circonscrire
l'extension du pass sanitaire qu'elle
considère comme une atteinte à très
forte aux libertés est ce que c'est un
avertissement que le gouvernement va
entendre selon le gouvernement n'entend
rien en réalité
il écoute il fait semblant il ya eu tous
ces instances délibératives la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
grand débat des modèles macron tout ça
c'est de la com c'est de la mise en
scène le gouvernement veut aller
vite dans la casse à la fois de la
république sociale mais aussi des
libertés donc que la cnil donne son avis
très bien je ne crois pas qu'il sera
entendu par le gouvernement
et d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se posent sur se passe ça
ni terre à la fois sur la durée de cette
application on ne sait pas on rentre là
dans un monde dont on ne connaît pas les
contours
est-ce que ce pass sanitaire va prendre
fin lors de la fin de la pandémie ou
bien est-ce que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui est déjà pour prolonger
jusqu'en décembre 2021 va durer toute la
vie
comme c'est le cas maintenant quasiment
des plans vigipirate dont on ne sort
plus et puis aussi quelles garanties sur
la protection des données de santé là on
est en train de demander aux français
d'être totalement transparent alors même
qu'un tel match on n'a publié qu'un seul
bulletin de santé en tant que président
de la république lorsqu'il a attrapé le
coc vide l'hiver dernier il se cachait
d'ailleurs derrière le secret médical
qui lui étaient dues comme à chaque
français là on a l'impression que les
français n'ont plus droit ni au secret
médical ni à la transparence n'y a rien
du tout avec des données qui vont
transiter sur des serveurs pas forcément
français où la question bien sûr de la
protection des données de l'état de
santé des français qui pourraient être
utilisées par des entreprises privées
encore une fois et en dépit bien sûr de
l'intérêt général
l'exécutif le gouvernement qui se montre
déterminé puisque le conseil
constitutionnel a été saisi par le
premier ministre jean castex à votre
avis quelle sera sa position et quels
sont les scénarios et les suites
possibles également alors je pense que
dans le moment ubuesque 1 de cette loi
liberticide de sanitaires vaguement
sanitaires devant le nombre
d'amendements qui ont été déposés les
débats qui vont se prolonger
le sénat ne pourra pas valider ça ce
week-end le conseil constitutionnel va
siffler la fin de la récré tout
simplement dix ans cette foire est vide
de sens inapplicable et dangereuse
ça ce serait un scénario idéal mais
quand on a vu le conseil d'état déjà
validé et accepté le principe même de se
passer ni terre alors qu'il ya quelques
semaines même conseil d'état disais
qu'il ne pouvait entrer en vigueur si
c'était pour réguler les activités
quotidiennes des français on voit que
toutes les barrières tombent les unes
après les autres
donc il se pourrait que le conseil
constitutionnel voyant le variant delta
arrivée se disent eh bien les
circonstances sont tellement
exceptionnel que c'en est fini des
libertés maintenant vous serez obligés
de scanner de mettre un qr code partout
et pour aller à la piscine au cinéma
ou ailleurs et alors même si jean castex
a dit hier lors d'une interview
télévisée qu'il n'y aurait pas de passe
annie terre pour les enfants à la
rentrée à l'école tout ça peut changer
dans les semaines qui viennent avec ses
lois d'exception qui changent d'une
semaine sur l'autre et je crois que
c'est là où jouer avec les nerfs des
français extrêmement dangereux parce que
ne pas savoir où on va jouer sur des
courbes de variants delta sans savoir si
les urgences vont être engorgé à la fin
août ou début septembre pousser les gens
la vaccination certes mais le faire avec
une telle violence
une telle haine finalement de la vie
c'est quelque chose qui est inacceptable
pour de nombreux français merci beaucoup
à vous à alex foulard je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes